نعم نحن هنا في درب السيل كما تشاهدون اا
هناك موكب موكب المنتخب الارجنتيني الذي
فاز بكاس العالم هنا في قطر بقياده ميسي
طبعا
نشاهد في الصوره الموكب الذي يقل
اللاعبون
وهم على متن هذه الحافله في الصوره
واذا شاهدنا الان مباشره بعد الخيول وبشكل
الحصيد العربيه
المنتخب الارجنتيني وهم على متن هذه
الحافله يقومون باجراء التحيه والقاء
التحيه على المشاج على المشجعين الذين
نشاهد هنا هذا هو المال ال- هذا هو
المنتخب الارجنتيني على متن هذه الحافله
يقومون همم بالقاء التحيه على جميع همم
المشجعين والذين يهتفون ميسي واسماء اخرى
من لاعبي المنتخب ويقولون فاموس ارخنتينا
لحظات تاريخيه لحظات تاريخيه ونشاهد ايضا
خلف حافله اللاعبين نشاهد الحافله الرسميه
التي تنقل اللاعبين بعد ذلك عندما ينتهي
من عبر ضرب الوزير او من عبور ضرب الوزير
همم من عبور ضرب الوسيل من عبور ضرب
الوسيل متجهين على متن حافلاتهم الى مكان
اقامتهم التي طبعا هناك ستقام احتفالات
خاصه لهم والجماهير بانتظارهم امام هذا
الفندق او مكان الاقامه ومن ثم تنتهي
الاحتفالات في ساعات الصباح الباكر ليله
الزاري العربيه الدوحه قطر